Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my walking dead episode
four video.
If you haven't seen it.
Just careful for spoilers, so here we go little
pig little pig let me know who Judith's real
father is.
I cannot believe that they did that that blew
my mind that's usually something that creators
keep really close to the vest and reveal at
conventions long after the shows gone off
the air like 10 years later someone's like,
so tell us finally who is Judith's father
but they kind of turned it into this metaphor
for them accepting the Negan situation is
a top 10 WTF and Easter eggs.
It was a 90 minute episode so I think the
biggest surprise number 10 is that they did
not slaughter someone during the episode like
you kinda thought for little while the Negan
was can open up on Olivia and when Spencer
got back they kind of teased you that Rick
might kill him just to show you that he's
not a total coward.
Now, even though he is definitely a little
gun shy like he gives omissions got so number
nine.
Giving them a shows gun at the end you could
see like her heartbreaks just a little bit
having to see Rick like this.
And she is pissed as hell.
But they kind of tried to get that across
through the episode so you know number eight,
most of the survivors or pissed and still
ready to double down just letting you know
that things are shit right now but it is not
the end number seven was Negan's entrance
little pig little pig let me and that was
a moment it was taken right out of the comics
as was the moment you know number six with
Carl kind of setting up where his arc is there
speeding through a really facile I don't know
how much of Carl story from the comics there
in a do.
But they kind of already given a lot of that
to Daryl's character so it makes me think
that they're not going to do a whole lot of
Carl Negan step from the comics he basically
stands at them you get out of here before
you find out how dangerous we are you can
see just how young Carl is in the comics.
When this is all happening compared to how
old he is on the TV show he's way older on
the TV show just because the actors aging
so much faster but number five meet Laura
she's another character from the comics and
she's on the kind of shouts out he has a couple
lines later in the episode when they're grabbing
all the guns she's actually from much later
in the comics compared to where they are right
now but she is important for Dwight's character
so I'm guessing that they're just speeding
up a lot of the white comic book story stuff
but number forward to me in the dig brigade
that was such a great moment when they grab
the RPG the one that Daryl used to kill them.
Those guys are bunch ass holes in nature.
So heartbroken when number three Dwight takes
his bike you can get this all back all you
gotta do is say, the thing that was also part
of Negan's deal when he was like maybe Daryl
can come back if he says the right thing.
He was talking about getting Daryl to say
the I'm Negan thing which you know Daryl flat
out refuses to say so is not getting the bike
back not coming back to the save zone anytime
soon that the look on his face is just priceless
the just so heartbreaking because in one moment
you see like the sadness in their eyes but
like also Rick to like it would zoom in on
Rick's face while he was holding Lucille there.
You also kind of think that he might make
a move in they found the bike that the place
they found it is actually where Denise was
killed.
That's why Rosita shouts her out when she
was looking for the gun in were Eugene bit
Dwight in the nuts.
They're basically rifling through like all
their keepsakes so a lot of them like Enid's
balloons had special significance he that
much sadder in the balloons were actually
from a Glenn episode that was how they signaled
the save zone and distract the walkers get
away.
So the reason she fought so hard to keep the
balloons was just to remember Glenn, but the
whole point of the episode was just to show
you how Negan walked in and use the save zone
like a target and regular number two has that
big speech where he says Negan's in charge.
So there's a whole lot of stuff happening
here like Rick is rolling over a really heartbreaking
way they use those moments of tension between
the characters.
This doesn't have to be our life like Rosita
at the end of the episode when she asked Eugene
to make her a bullet to show you that is not
the end of a number one craziest moment was
actually a tie between Negan's taught at the
end of the episode which is also right out
of the comics totally not safe for work I
just live my business down your throat and
you think me for it.
That like literally right out of the comic
book and then the other Shane speech where
Rick remember Shane and acknowledges Judith
as his daughter was just completely blew my
mind.
It'd been a joke in the fandom for a long
time to say hi yeah baby Judith.
Probably Shane's daughter, but since they
said it in an episode it's almost cannon like
the way Rick says that he just believes that
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's totally
true be can choose to take it how you will
see you can let me know.
Do you believe Rick when he says that Judith
is Shane's daughter.
And even is crazy as that was in the whole
episode it was still fun to remember Shane
every once in a while whenever they get the
opportunity but just to reference the smoking
tiger in the room.
Rick says they don't have enough manpower
they reference hilltop.
You know, even with them.
We don't have enough they don't know about
the kingdom in Ezekiel yet select next week
will go to hilltop Jesus actually knows a
lot more about what's going on with all the
different factions so hopefully he'll have
some of the rallying cry for the survivors
that want to stand up to Negan I think that's
probably what they'll build up to for the
midseason finale is that they'll be like another
big conflict with the saviors.
So if you haven't read the comics there is
like a big conflict called all out war but
it's like leave further ahead in the comics
like it's not anywhere near what's happening
right now.
Do you think that that's what they're going
to be doing this season like will just blow
through a whole bunch of comic book plot and
get there faster because there's a whole bunch
more comic book stuff that they can do on
the TV show but it just depends on how fast
they moved so if they actually do end up doing
stuff like that you know when it happens in
episodes I'll try to pointed out like when
it happened in the comics you don't actually
have to read the comics understand what's
going on.
They did a pretty good job of leading you
through the episode, especially with the way
they tried to tip you off with Rosita with
the bullets so it's like okay yeah there very
clearly can stand up to Negan eventually but
not right away and speaking of hilltop for
those you wondering about the Maggie they
Know she's not dead that they were originally
taking her to the doctor at hilltop because
of the baby when they ran into Negan before
episode one happened.
So when they left her she just continued on
their so will probably pick back up with her
when we see hilltop and next week's episode,
but the reason why they told Negan she was
dead is just to throw him off her sent member
he was like a lighthouse to get about making
a play for even though I just killed her husband
but he was definitely rubbing Rick's nose
in it all episode so it is gonna make the
payoff the ultimate payoff.
However long it takes to get there that much
more satisfying.
So next week Jesus is back be sure to subscribe
to get that video I will do a trailer video
tomorrow and there is a new walking dead giveaway
that's going on right now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video and just a heads up.
It doesn't look like they're going to be any
breaks in the episodes before the midseason
finale that's episode eight which is currently
scheduled for December 11.
So if there is a change the schedule and they
go on break or something like that all totally
do a video about it but that does sound about
right that they would have their midseason
finale sometime earlier in December but it
is gonna be any issues with that.
So walking dead trailer posting tomorrow what
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for that Dave Chapelle walking dead skit
and you can click here for my ghost in the
Shell trailer video thank you so much watching
everybody high five and I'll see you guys
tonight!